we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P yesterday on the bonus
show we talked about the culinary scam
that is the boneless chicken wing it's
not a wing and a lot of people called in
here's one voicemail
hey David you know I was listening to
the
the explanation you gave around the
terrible false advertising with the
boneless chicken wings
you know they're not real wings at all
it would be like you know somebody
taking a liquid made from soy or almonds
or something like that and then you coin
it something like milk which is not at
all you know you just use that marketing
because it sounds better you know as Pat
was saying listen we talked about this
you can make a case that almond milk
shouldn't be labeled as milk because
it's not milk you could make the case
that a boneless wing shouldn't be called
a wing because it's a chicken breast
right or a tenderloin my view on this is
sort of uh uh if we agree that we can
name things based on their usage almond
milk and oat milk are used functionally
as milks and that would be an argument
for saying you can call it milk the
Counterpoint would be and this is the
one that big Dairy says it's not milk
and therefore you can't really call it
milk I don't know what the answer is but
it's getting very very complicated we
have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com I'll see you
then